hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one main reason
for the importance of this dialogue the
Meno within
Plato's body of work is that in it
there's a doctrine which which is going
to run throughout the Platonic corpus
and get invoked from place to place and
get added to and and get get a you know
modified in certain ways but it's coming
out here in the Meno and it's what we
can call the doctrine of recollection or
remembrance and this is a way of
explaining what happens when we actually
develop knowledge so it's also about
teaching and learning what is going on
when somebody is teaching another person
are they taking knowledge se out of
their own head and putting it into
theirs are they perhaps directing them
towards features of the objects that
they're they're trying to study are they
providing them with some sort of
artifact which then gets impressed upon
them or is there something else going on
and Socrates and Plato is the answer to
this is yes there is indeed something
else going on and this may sound a bit
paradoxical to many people but again
very central to Plato's ideas
that knowledge or at least certain kinds
of knowledge is really a matter of
recollection of remembering that means
that the knowledge is in some way
already within us at least within our
minds or our souls and it's a matter of
bringing to light what we don't quite
realize yet that we already know so this
is an attractive doctrine to quite a few
people and I want to be very clear in
distinguishing this from some new agey
beliefs that seem to say something
similar because Plato sang something
quite different you notice a previous
life and present life up here and plain
one does not have in mind previous life
as you know like a version of the
current life just you know way back then
that's what we call the doctrine of
reincarnation Plato actually does seem
to have believed in or taught a doctrine
of reincarnation where the soul is at
death freed from the body the soul
continues to live and that it is
reincarnated as is put back into another
body but something really important
happens with the soul in these intervals
before it goes into another body that's
what the past life refers to that's what
the memory is going back to so I'm not
remembering my past life as you know the
warrior Trog or something like that that
would be a life within this body this is
happening in a different kind of
existence the world of the forms you're
gonna see this discussed in you know the
Phaedrus discussed in the Phaedo
discussed in a lot of different places
here in the Meno he invokes some of the
the mystery religions and he's giving
his own interpretation of it and he
doesn't flesh it out completely but he
doesn't actually need to he gets across
the main
he wants to do and you know so get this
sort of diagram up here I think this
will help us to wrap our heads around it
so the idea is we're here in this
present life and there's something that
we don't know that we don't understand
and somebody else is teaching us about
it now it is the teacher himself or
herself implanting knowledge into our
soul Plato says no a lot of us would say
yes or you know we might also say well
you know the teacher doesn't actually
like you know pour knowledge in but what
they do is they they create the learning
environment for the student that would
be a little bit closer to a Plato saying
but there's something else that's really
important that's being left out in that
you know fancy new educational theory
and it's this that the reason why one is
able to learn anything and this current
life is that one is recognizing things
that one has knowledge or had knowledge
about in the previous life when the soul
was freed of the body and actually saw
some things straight on face to face
Plato doesn't say here that those are
the forms but you can presume you know
given the other Platonic doctrines that
what we're talking about here really the
forms of things and the soul had direct
contact with them the soul was able to
get to know them so if knowledge did
happen or develop if learning in the
strict sense took place it took place
back then Socrates doesn't tell us very
much about that and and you know that's
not where the real emphasis needs to lie
here although if we wanted to go further
in Plato's scholarship that is a
question we want to think about so what
is it what implications is that there
for the present life
you notice I'm getting capital T and
small T just to sort of get across that
these are sort of like the archetypes
the patterns the the things that we're
recognizing so when were placed in
conned
with the world of things which are in
some respect copies or not go offs or
imitations of the other things the they
jog our memory but they only do it a
little bit they bring it to mind to us
for a space and we might lose that
window if we don't if we're not careful
with it we might you know have something
come to mind saying oh yeah I think I
recognize that there's something there
and then we get distracted and I know
we're paying attention to something else
and then we forget about that we lapse
back into forgetting so really what's
happening here is the goal is to get
ourselves out of a realm of
forgetfulness of not awareness and so
that can happen by contact with the
things we start to remember we start to
recall and Plato and Socrates say that
this is an approximative iterative
process it's not something that we can
do all at once and it's done that's not
real knowledge we have to do it over and
over and over again and we do it through
dialectic and it really helps to have a
teacher who's able to get by that help
bring that knowledge of previous things
back into our awareness and you know
there could be there could be some
principles for this sort of teaching but
one one would presumably have to
recognize this process going on within
oneself and be you know a little bit
further along than the student and we
see this within Socrates discussion with
the servant boy of Meno we who has some
study geometry and and Socrates is able
to get him to figure out what the
proportions ought to be if you want to
take a square and come up with another
square that is exactly double in in size
double in size of covering area of the
former square this turns out to be kind
of a tricky
call or geometrical rather problem and
the young servant or slave tries a few
different solutions maybe it's you know
maybe the the side needs to be four
times as long that doesn't work maybe
three times as long that doesn't work
it actually has to cover you know a
smaller area and what Socrates is doing
according to this this theory is he's
not implanting knowledge in young man
he's drawing on what the young man is
able to do with the things in front of
him he's bringing the knowledge out of
the young man helping him to remember oh
yeah that's the case and oh yeah that's
the case is this a satisfactory
demonstration of this doctrine many
scholars would say no that we could
explain this in other ways Plato seems
to think that it is and I I'm less
interested in whether this particular
case demonstrates it and I'm more
interested in asking another question as
we wrap this up does Plato have to be
committed as it does seem at several
places in the dialogue to saying that
all knowledge and all learning is really
recollection of things in a previous
life or could he be saying two other
things one of these would be to say well
there's some types of knowledge that
actually are knowledge of things that we
had when the soul was unencumbered by
the body when I was able to see the
patterns or forms or ideas straight on
and face to face no no mixture of
anything else but other things there are
other kinds of knowledge Plato doesn't
actually say that at this point but he
he could be an available thing when I
recognized human being and a person over
there that would be presumably the first
kind of
when I recognized that human being as my
brother-in-law or as the tax assessor or
as some famous actor something like that
that would be a different kind of
knowledge because I would have generated
that within the conditions of this life
you see the difference between those now
another possibility would be to say and
this would be a little bit more
complicated that not all knowledge is
knowledge coming from a previous life
but that all knowledge involves
knowledge we're all learning all coming
to to know about things in the present
life involves in some way knowledge that
was acquired in this past life before we
began to live in a body that could be
what Plato is saying as well if he's
saying that all knowledge and all
learning is really you know drawing out
of previous life you know mathematics
maybe that makes sense
moral philosophy arguably you know the
virtues he thinks that they're forms but
a lot of other things you know
especially where it's you know very
bodily types of manners that doesn't
seem to fit so I think that it's good to
attribute to Plato doctrines or readings
of doctrines that actually would make
sense that that he would actually be
able say yes I respond to your
objections of that in any case to wrap
this up if you had to boil it down to
just you know a few bullet points
knowledge and learning according to
Plato in this life is really remembering
it were unforgettable we learned in a
previous existence and existence where
we worked in
body it wasn't a previous life like past
life regressions or anything like that
but some other state of the soul